[Music]
thank you
towards giving
[Music]
now
one would imagine
that I created this that
perhaps me you know smoking what I
shouldn't has turned on this fire alarm
but
this tour is giving
fire alarm brought to you by
a burnt Frito pie
done by live Roush
let this be a lesson to your kids
don't go vegan
[Applause]
all I asked for was a Frito pie
wanted a Thanksgiving Frito pie that's
all
the first tour is giving
um the pilgrims across the land
uh 50 shows uh to get to the new world
and uh the new world was here and when
they landed they talked to the locals we
sent a [ __ ] fire department because
the Credo bar was burned and thus the
first tourist was born
um on tour is giving uh we list the
things we are thankful for so it is kind
of an off-brand Thanksgiving we take a
lot of the same tenants kind of the way
that the Christian faith took a lot from
pagans same day I am thankful for the
both of you because there's nobody else
here to [ __ ] think yeah uh here's for
proximity I love you both very much and
I'm thankful for my first feature coming
out here next week
[Applause]
long long pocket.com
yeah
[Applause]
um I'm thankful for
what's your favorite song
we could hum along
well I think you're smart you sweet
thing
I'm dying here
I am grateful that in the late 1950s
um his allergies were so bad that his
parents moved him to Lancaster
California which closer to me Captain
beefheart and then for example with one
very grateful thank you so much
you don't miss
thankful for
Chef keeping here and I'm thankful to
still be alive when I get a kid and
she's alive and my wife is alive
thankful to reconnect with old friends
for uh this Feast which did nothing died
for us to eat
except
my humility when the fire department
showed up and assumed that I was the one
setting the alarm off because I'm the
old [ __ ] hippie Stoner when really it
was
Frito pie that was burnt with love
so uh Happy tourist game
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]